tout le monde pense que lorsque nous parlons du vih,
ce doit être cette chose traumatisante
et le
traumatisme fait partie de l'expérience et du
voyage, mais aussi le vih a apporté tellement de
joie, de bonheur et d'amour dans ma vie que
je ne changerais cela pour rien au monde
[Musique  ]
je m'appelle robbie lawler je viens d'avoir
31 ans et je suis doctorant à l'
université de dublin j'ai également co-fondé l'accès
aux médicaments en irlande parce que je suis vraiment
intéressé par un accès équitable aux
technologies de la santé dans le monde
[musique]
j'ai été diagnostiqué  en 2012, je n'arrive pas à croire que
c'était il y a près d'une décennie, c'est comme un
tiers de ma vie et je pense que l'Irlande a
tellement changé au cours de ces années et
avec elle a été cet élan de gens
comprenant un peu plus le vih et
comprenant ce que c'est que de vivre
avec le vih
je dis toujours que nous vivons à l'âge d'or
du vih je prends juste une pilule par jour pour
maintenir les concentrations de ce médicament
à un certain niveau où le vih reste
endormi et ce que cela signifie également que je
ne peux pas transmettre le vih sexuellement  le risque est
nul
[Musique]
quand on m'a diagnostiqué le vih en
2012, il y avait comme une
organisation de soutien appelée open heart house et
je me souviens avoir lu le journal et il dit que
open heart house ferme
et laissez-moi vous dire aux gens qui étaient
des utilisateurs de services  de maison à cœur ouvert ont été
écrasés c'était la seule communauté
qu'ils pensaient avoir qui m'a amené
à vouloir fournir un soutien par les pairs aux
gens de ce pays
[Musique]
l'art était un médium brillant dans lequel
nous pouvions recueillir les histoires de chacun et les
apporter  à un public qui n'aurait peut-être
pas entendu les
messages normaux sur le vih et la pièce que
nous avons faite s'appelait rapids, puis le conseil irlandais des
arts nous a donné un financement pour
en faire un film intitulé comment dire un secret une
autre chose sur laquelle j'ai travaillé  sur
moi-même et veda,
il était également sur la façon de raconter un film secret que
nous jouons, nous avons créé un podcast
l'idée de faire un podcast
flottait dans l'éther et j'étais
devenu obsédé par l'idée de faire un
pa  utiliser la diffusion d'un podcast séropositif et j'étais
à la recherche de quelqu'un qui en
savait beaucoup plus sur le vih que moi parce
que ce que je savais était ma propre expérience, alors j'ai
sauté directement et j'ai dit que nous devrions faire
un podcast ensemble, vous savez pour plate
-forme le  des histoires d'autres personnes comme nous
vivant avec le vih et il m'a
immédiatement répondu par SMS en disant oui, bien sûr, allons-y
[La musique]
n'a pas d'importance si le public de deux
personnes ou de 500 personnes, nous sommes là pour
partager nos histoires et répondre à toutes les
questions  autour du vih et veda est un
comédien chanteur c'est une vraie performance
c'est éducatif c'est amusant c'est juste une
situation gagnant-gagnant
vous